[Applaudissements]
l'annulation de l'eau contre wade a eu
l'effet d'une bougie d'allumage elles
ont envahi le parvis du palais de
justice à montréal en solidarité avec
les américaines c'est militante de
longue date ne croyait pas devoir
reprendre le plan d'eau puis ça me
décourage un décourage
complètement consternés des basses t es
en colère ce que je veux dire à ces
dictateurs de nos corps ce que nos corps
en 2022 il ne leur appartiennent pas et
ils n'ont pas à fin
[Musique]
ni des lois ni d antigua qui viennent
agir sur nos corps on élit des talents
des sorcières si vous n'avez pas pu
brûler les femmes craignent que le vent
conservateur du sud ne soufflent sur le
parlement canadien c'est pas vrai que
tout est acquis ici soutenu et d'être
réveillés parce que les gens qui sont
contre l'avortement oui donc huit ans à
nous tous l'érosion des droits des
femmes concerne tout le monde rappelle
cet homme c'est pas juste une attaque
aux droits des femmes sont un tacot
droits de tout le monde fondé la famille
quand ils veulent où ils le veulent ils
et elles le veulent les voix des
féministes se sont fait entendre aux
quatre coins de la province à rimouski
sherbrooke trois rivières à québec cette
mère a dû se faire avorter sujet encore
tabou fait dans ma famille
kousair d'avortement dans les
générations prcg des proches venus
apporter moi même j'ai dû avorter avec
parce qu'on peut tomber enceinte avec
contraception qui est sûr à 100% une
femme sur trois aura à subir un
avortement dans sa vie selon la
fédération du québec des planning des
naissances bien que le droit à
l'avortement soit mieux protégé au
canada son excès et inégale on veut
aussi faire en sorte de le rendre plus
accessible partout à travers le pays
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a investi
45 millions de dollars dans ce sens là
donc au canada notre enjeu c'est plutôt
d'augmenter l'accès un accès qui s'est
refermée pour des millions d'américaines
un mépris envers toutes les femmes
disent les féministes qui n'auront
d'autre choix que de reprendre le combat
ici marie josée paquet comme radio
canada montréal